[Musique]
Molière faudrait
reprendre place au
théâtre nous perdons des sommes
considérable avec cette nouvelle pièce
faudrait reprendre nicomè je n'ai pas de
talent pour la tragédie un bouffon reste
un bouffon un bouffon peut-être mais je
joue pour le roi on dit que c'est
Corneille qui a écrit le tartuf il
n'aurait pas osé le
signer tu es sûr de pouvoir continuer il
faut continuer il y a 50 personnes qui
n'ur rien à manger le RO va venir
Jean-Baptiste votre corps est épuisé je
sens de temps en temps des douleurs de
tête
[Musique]
justement pour être enterré au chrétien
il faudrait qu'il écrveite une lettre de
renonciation à son métier je ne suis pas
au service de l'Église je suis au
service du
roi si tu ne signes pas on va te jeter
en pleine nuit dans la fausse commune la
troupe va se déchirer surans lui la
troupe existait avant lui toujours pas
s'il Meur tout est fini et tout
commencerait pour d'autres le roi m'a
trah l'église m
[Musique]
trah je vais tâcher de ne pas rater mon
entrée il m'a
[Musique]
sorti
faudrait trouver un nouveau nom qui
convienne à tous La Comédie Française ça
ne marchera
[Musique]
jamais